so first off I was wondering what are
the pros and the cons of directing a
movie where you wrote the script versus
directing something that someone else
wrote ah the pros are you just know it
like you really intrinsically know it
you know exactly why you wrote every
single word so the connection to me is
is much deeper when you've written your
own project and like so much more
focused about how I want to bring it to
the screen but sometimes you read a
script you really love and you're like I
want to direct this I wish I had written
it that's kind of my feeling on scripts
I haven't written like do I feel like
jealous to it like I wish I had written
it does having written the script make
you less likely to let your actors
improvise a bit on sex you have a button
combo in this movie and this ensemble
that are incredible yeah at Department
know if I have comedians you know like
if you have someone like row like you
let him play you know there's definitely
scenes in the movie where I just let him
like play for four minutes he is really
something else yes he makes a huge
impression yes a little bit of screen
time can you tell me a little bit about
working with Issa and Keith now because
both of them in this movie are doing
something that isn't necessarily what we
know them for so jumping into a project
like this and something so different for
them where do you find the confidence
that they can nail it I mean I had
worked with ISA before on her show and
so I kind of had gotten a peek into all
the little nuances of her performance
and then if you spend time with her as
well you know like she's just very
impressive very smart very thoughtful
and I thought she could bring all those
characters to me so I wasn't worried and
then look he you know I had a
conversation with him
you know and we're on skype and he was
just like so kind of soulful and
thoughtful about the script you know and
connected with it in a personal way and
I was just like I think he can you know
knock this out of the park they're both
very you know to have a lot of range
ISA an American princess yeah you know
I'm curious what are we gonna get from
that comedy that we don't really see on
screen often enough and what is the next
layer of her and yeah I mean she's such
a gifted comedic actress so it'd be
exciting to do like a comedy feature
with her as well I mean I mean you've
never seen kind of an african-american
girl go to England and go abroad really
and the I mean I feel like there's a
Queen Latifah movie but I have to go
back and look at which one but it's like
you know it's it's fun to have
international location yeah yeah that's
for sure I came forward to to seeing
that and also with working with Paul
Feig or I think it's one of the great
guys out there the comic genius but one
thing that I kind of know the answer to
but I want our viewers to know this
story is who you found to shoot the
photographs in this movie because about
that yeah that seems like a
one-of-a-kind opportunity yeah I mean I
found a young photographer named Jada
Miguel who's kind of making a name for
herself you know in the art scene in New
York and I didn't even really talked to
her I just saw her photos and I just
loved them and we ended up hiring her
and I just sent her down to Louisiana to
do Kristina's portfolio and she brought
along Noel with her and casted you know
some guys down there and got on a boat
and it was just beautiful like I have
her photographs like all at home now
yeah she was finishing her thesis at NYU
she's a kid she's like 22 I really can't
even imagine being in that situation
thing else she's definitely special